what about all the dead people who voted  where was that held in court i don't  know  sarah we like film this program sarah i  like how piers says  he likes her on the program i find her  completely insufferable and corrosive to  american politics he likes her okay  more votes than people wasn't  demonstrated anywhere just because they  repeat it doesn't make it true  and then dead people voting come on it's  been so widely debunked every time it's  been investigated dead people voting  were actually  a combination of people who were  registered but died before the election  and didn't vote being registered to vote  and then dying and not voting isn't a  crime it's not shenanigans it's not foul  play  clerical errors  some junior senior confusion